[Musique]
je
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
mode d'emploi elle est présente partout
dans le sol dans l'air dans notre corps
il suffit d'ouvrir le robinet pour la
voir couler vous avez deviné il s'agit
de l'eau mais que sait-on vraiment sur
cet élément essentiel à la vie saviez
vous qu'un étang doit être entretenu une
rivière nettoyer et l'eau d'une fontaine
purifier mode d'emploi vous dit tout sur
le travail en milieu aquatique et en
rivière lac derrière ses grandes
étendues d'eau se cachent des métiers
aquatique très divers et qui ont la cote
cette filière offre de nombreux
débouchés
un secteur qui emploie cent cinquante
mille personnes et recrute régulièrement
sur saint quentin en yvelines la filière
eau représente 42 entreprises et un
total de 515 salariés la france n'ayant
pas de problème pour alimenter son
territoire en haut et se concentre
davantage sur sa qualité
plus de 80 métiers ont donc vu le jour
comme technicien de laboratoire ou sur
site de production ou d'assainissement
de l'eau conducteur de stations
d'épuration ou bien encore technicien de
rivière les postes que l'on retrouve
dans des laboratoires dans des bureaux
d'études en gestion des eaux en usine de
production d'eau potable ou dans des
sites de traitement et d'assainissement
des eaux usées
si les hommes occupent encore 75% du
secteur
les femmes sont de plus en plus
nombreuses sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
il est possible de se former à
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
de trappes ou à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lacs étangs rivières marc au fond elles
n'auront plus de secrets pour vous
se former aux métiers de la filière eau
c'est la possibilité de travailler de la
ressource jusqu'à son retour dans le
milieu naturel
après traitement ou bien en laboratoire
ou sur le terrain ou bien encore pour
des entreprises dans le conseil ou l'
expertise nous allons voir ça dans
quelques instants
mais juste avant voici votre sommaire
cette semaine je vous emmène à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour découvrir une formation
pluridisciplinaire unique devenir
technicien environnement en laboratoire
ou en exploitation afin de travailler
dans la filière production et traitement
de l'eau puis nous irons à trappes dans
la nouvelle pépinière chrysalide du
quartier des merisiers nous verrons
comment la société océanis environnement
entretien et réhabilite les milieux
aquatiques
revenons quelques instants sur
l'histoire de l'eau dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines a une
longue histoire qui remonte à la
construction et à l'élaboration de cette
ville nouvelle
il a fallu bien évidemment gérer les
eaux pluviales et le défi était majeur
puisque nous nous situons sur un plateau
ce cette gestion des eaux pluviales a
été réalisé à partir de systèmes
hydrauliques très performant vous avez
sur saint quentin un grand nombre de
bassins qui aujourd'hui apparaissent
pour la majorité des habitants comme des
lieux d'agrément mais qui sont avant
tout des lieux de fonctionnement
hydraulique de
de saint quentin depuis février dernier
huit communes sur 12 bénéficie d'un
nouveau service à une eau des carbonates
et la décarbonatation c'est quoi c'est
le fait tout simplement d'abaisser le
taux de calcaire présents dans l'eau ce
taux de calcaire il a été abaissé
aujourd'hui de près de la moitié je me
trouve actuellement à l'unité de
formation et de recherche des sciences
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines à ce campus
scientifique accueille plus de 3500
étudiants 270 enseignants et 60
chercheurs
c'est ici que l'on forme entre autres
des techniciens supérieurs de la filière
les professionnels aptes à travailler
ton laboratoire que sur le terrain sans
plus attendre je vous invite à découvrir
ses futurs médecins de l'eau former des
techniciens supérieurs de la filière
hausse et d'objectifs de la licence
professionnelle chimie m
ea métiers de l'eau et de
l'assainissement que propose
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
une formation qui offre de nombreux
débouchés les possibilités c'est tout ce
qui travaille au laboratoire laboratoire
de chimie physique ou chimie
microbiologie ou radio analyse sans
oublier le prélèvement les échantillons
la deuxième partie c'est tout ce qui est
exploitation produire le plus simple
produire de l'eau potable ou alors
traiter des eaux usées il ya aussi tout
l'aspect réseau c'est que l'eau il faut
la transporter l'eau potable est potable
a senti une usine elle doit l'être
encore en arrivant au robinet du client
et après il ya aussi tout ce qu'est
activités de conseil
comment fonctionnent les exploitations
comment doit-on faire les branchements
est-ce que c'est conforme à ce que ça
les bons pour un gêneur apprentis en
l'essence m eur
les objectifs étaient très claires
personnellement j'étais plus sur le
terrain donc je vais avoir ainsi
l'aspect c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi
laboratoires sont les résultats pour
pouvoir mieux interpréter les résultats
de
que j'avais en fait sur maison je
travaille personnellement ça son
épuration et j'ai pour projet de pouvoir
c'est possible mettre en place un
système humanitaire dans
l'assainissement dans les pays où il n'a
pas ou dans les endroits peut être assez
de recul
une formation l'alternance permet aux
apprentis et d'être directement
confrontés à des mises en situation
réelle au niveau de leur entreprise et
dans des missions extrêmement variées
certains sont en bureau d'étude font du
contrôle d'autres en usine en
exploitation certains sont en
laboratoire et vont donc développé des
spécificités propres à leur poste de
travail
j'ai trouvé un poste d'apprenti dans un
laboratoire de production en
microbiologie
donc j'ai effectué des analyses de
routine pour des autres distributions
près
mon but ce serait de trouver un
d'après l'information trouver un travail
son laboratoire sans exploitation
d'assainissement puisque c'est quelque
chose qui me plaît énormément aidé à 10
ans permet vraiment de balayer tous les
domaines et de conforter nos
connaissances des partenariats
formaliser des deux grands groupes sont
également un plus de l'information le
dsq travaille notamment avec de grandes
entreprises des yvelines quelques suez
et la siaap ces entreprises accueille
des apprentis mais ces entreprises
participent aux cours dans notre cas de
figure
plus d'un tiers des cours sont assurés
par des professionnels et non des
universités cette formation en
alternance permet d'acquérir de solides
connaissances tant dans la production
que le traitement de l'eau mais aussi
sur sa qualité sont les mêmes normes
soient s'intéresse à de l'eau potable à
de l'eau de baignade l'autre boisson à
la qualité des rejets dans les stations
d'épuration et donc toutes ces qualités
sont définis donc par des normes et donc
sont contrôlées par des analyses donc
des analyses physico-chimiques des
analyses microbiologiques mais aussi
même des analyses de radioactivité
donc le premier travail c'est d'être
déjà en mesure soit de faire soit de
lire ses analyses c'est la base de ces
métiers de là c'est la qualité de l'eau
tracy apprentis en alternance à l'ufr
des sciences de l'université travaille
pour la société merck de guyancourt et
la qualité de l'eau elle sait ce que
c'est puisque c'est sa mission au
laboratoire en cours on étudie les
différents paramètres à observer vous
vérifier la qualité de l'eau et en
entreprise on vérifie enfin on apprend
les différentes méthodes d'analysé grâce
à son banc de capacités dynamiques
j'ai pu valider la réalisation pack de
purification et en sortie de cette
machine on peut considérer que notre eau
est ultra purs une mise en situation en
entreprise qui lui permet d'acquérir une
expérience et des gestes professionnels
donc afin de purifier l'eau nous
utilisons différents mélanges qui sont
réalisés en osier composé de charbon
actif dans les dunes anioniques et
cationiques et pour vérifier la
composition du mélange
nous effectuons des tests d'uniformité
l'alternance un intérêt double pour
l'entreprise et pour l'apprenti
fait d'intégrer des apprentis au sein de
structures est vraiment primordial pour
nous ils ont vraiment une vraie mission
au sens où ils ont un objectif de stage
ils font les manipulations qu'on leur
demande
il doit faire le rapport de stage
comprendre leurs résultats et tout ça
permet de faire une vraie expérience
professionnelle c'est à dire que ils ne
font pas que manny paix mais il délivre
des résultats et ils les comprennent et
ils permettent de valider
potentiellement des process restons dans
le monde de travailler dans le secteur
de l'eau avec une visite à trappes de la
petite entreprise mais néanmoins très
active de monsieur et ben ami un
entrepreneur au service de l'eau fondée
en avril 2010 service environnement est
une entreprise très présence dans le
secteur de l'entretien et de la
réhabilitation des milieux aquatiques
son directeur jean et ben ami et
biologiste de formation et connaît tous
des rivières des bassins et des
fontaines
à l'origine je travaillais dans une
société spécialisée dans le traitement
biologique des effluents au sein de
cette société j'ai développé le
traitement biologique des plans d'eau
j'ai trouvé tout à fait naturel de me
jeter à l'eau en criant océanis
environnement la société propose des
expertises sur mesure aux collectivités
locales ou aux grandes entreprises parmi
sa large palette d'intervention elle
pratique le faucardage la coupe des
végétaux dans un plan d'eau ça se fait à
l'aide de matos au quart d'heure on adam
verticale une lame horizontal qui coupe
les végétaux il remonte en surface on
les récupère pour les évacuer on
installe des jets d'eau dans les milieux
aquatiques
parce qu'il ya des pièces d'eau qui sont
lacustre c'est à dire il n'y a pas de
dynamique une pièce d'eau où il n'ya pas
d'ennemis
entraîne certains problèmes c'est à dire
les problèmes d'odeurs le jet d'eau
oxygène et dont ça évite ce problème
d'odeur on fait des jardins aquatiques
ont des bassins d'agrément ont fait la
réflexion des berges on les stabilise en
génie végétal ou en génie minérales ont
fait du curage c'est l'action d'évacuer
des boues qui sédimentent dans un bassin
l'entretien aussi les fontaines
publiques et dont l'entretien qui permet
d'avoir des fontaines avec lino de très
bonne qualité et c'est lors de la
végétalisation d'une fontaine que nous
avons suivi l'une des équipes d'océanis
environnement et entre les deux s'est
reposé bray vous remettez la roma
aujourd'hui on a fait une intervention
mensuel on arrête les fontaines on vide
le bassin de toi on entretient et
organes mécaniques en haut tu fais la
mise en eau et la remise en service de
l'affronter entouré d'une équipe
spécialisée en milieu aquatique
monsieur est bannie travail avait des
électro mécaniciens et techniciens de
ces deux lots les premiers entretiens
les pompes et les organes
électromécanique lé second s'occupe de
la reprise des berges de l'entretien des
bassins et des fontaines et des jets
d'eau ces deux profils sont
indispensables on a besoin d'avoir du
personnel non seulement qualifiée mais
surtout passionné si vous êtes un
passionné par les milieux aquatiques
vous ne restez pas longtemps c'est
difficile c'est complexe
c'est pas la nature qui s'adapte à notre
métier c'est nous qui nous adaptons à la
nature des conditions contraignantes
mais pour un résultat personnel très
gratifiant ce qui me plaît dans ce
métier c'est la polyvalence
on est amené à faire de l'espace vert de
la maçonnerie ont fait on répare hanté
tout ce qui est
et bordures le bassin on voit qu'il est
beau mais en fait ça demande beaucoup
beaucoup d'entretien il faut vider les
bassins passer le karcher et ça demande
du temps ça demande beaucoup d'énergie
mais en fait ça c'est plaisant parce
qu'après le résultat et les magnifiques
je travaille dans le bâtiment
c'est bien s'il a d'autres choses à
découvrir d'autres sites
c'est ce qui me plaît c'est la
polyvalence mais autre chose et c'est
également une force d'océanis
environnement développé une grande
polyvalence et faire preuve de
réactivité
lorsque les cas particuliers se présente
pour avoir une eau limpide et
parallèlement avoir la capacité de
développer les plantes aquatiques notre
photo m nous a permis de faire les
essais sur soi pour moi pour trouver le
bon dosage
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui nous sommes
capables de pouvoir développer des
plantes aquatiques dans une fontaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
si océanis environnement vous a donné
envie de travailler dans les milieux
aquatiques
sachez que vous pouvez retrouver de
nombreuses informations pour vous aider
à construire votre parcours
professionnel
à la cité des métiers de saint quentin
en yvelines le 29 mai prochain de 9h30 à
11h la cité des métiers vous donne
également rendez vous un atelier sur la
sensibilisation et la gestion du stress
et puisque le calendrier s'y prête
sachez que le 30 mai de 10 heures à midi
vous pourrez participer à un atelier sur
la préparation des concours de la
fonction publique
vous saurez tout sur les conditions à
remplir les dates et les inscriptions
pour terminer la cité des métiers vous
propose un zoom sur la fonction d'agent
de gare sncf
notez bien que tous ces ateliers se font
sur inscription alors ne tardez pas
quant à moi je vous retrouve bientôt
pour un nouveau mode d'emploi mais d'ici
là bien sûr prenez soin de vos
[Musique]